My whole life,
I always wondered
what my birth family was like.
Open it.
My mama had six babies
at the same time!
We're sextuplets!
Maybe one of them
changed their name
to Idris Elba.
You know, we do have
strikingly similar
bone structure.
You're my brother, Russell!
Come here!
This is awkward.
All right, shush. Hey.
Stranger danger!
I decided to join you
to find our siblings.
Good night, Alan.
Hey, man, you naked!
The buck is beautiful.
Boy, if you don't
put some damn clothes on.
So, you're a stripper?
What the hell?
A stripper and exotic dancer
are different.
See this? Plié,relevé,
ass on face.
Please, don't do that.
Ethan?
You smell like money.
No, you got...
you got
Republican money, huh?
Hey!
You know I'm a Bernie Bro.
You shop at Whole Foods.
I am free!
I was about to
El Chapo this bitch.
What in the
Real Housewives of Atlanta
is this?
Thank you, brother!
Baby Pete is in the hospital.
Alan!
It's not every day that
a long-lost family member
appears out of thin air
to donate a kidney.
You said what?
Why my kidney?
Why don't you take
one of theirs?
Don't look at me,
'cause I sniffed
way too much laptop cleaner
and I popped a molly
yesterday.
I want some molly.
Just gotta find
the rest of 'em.
Hood slide!
I always wanted to do that.
These past few days
have been the greatest
-of my life.
-My doe.
Since we hit the road together,
I've done things
I've only seen on television.
Pillow fight!
Now that's...
how you pillow fight!